France has this very distinct notion about
what it means to create an inclusionary society
that really comes out of the ideals of the
French Revolution, which is that anyone can
become French, but they need to accept that
what it means to be a French citizen is to
be kind of unencumbered in the public sphere.
And what could be a hindrance in the public
sphere includes things like loyalty to the
country from which you came if you're an immigrant,
loyalty to an ethno-religious group. So, that
means that a certain level of integration
can only be achieved if you are sort of looking
French, speaking French, seeming French like
everybody else in public. Now one of the things
I do try to argue in the book is that this
was always more rhetoric and myth at a certain
level than reality. Particularly during the
imperial period, France is sort of of necessity
a multi-ethnic empire, given how vast its
geographical reach is and how diverse it's
becoming already in the twenties and thirties.
In the case of Jews, in particular, Jews have
been thought about as sort of by far the most
important ethno-religious minority in modern
French history, this kind of "test case" for
French democracy, this way of measuring how
inclusive France is at different historical moments.
In the case of Muslims, Muslims have
largely been located outside of mainland France
in what's been written about Muslims in relation
to France, until thinking about them, you
know, toward the end of the twentieth century,
beginning of the twenty-first century. And
they've been thought about really as colonized
subjects, as resistors against colonialism,
rather than as people who lived in relatively
significant numbers already a series of different
kinds of lives in the mainland from the teens
and twenties onward. And, so, when we put
Jews and Muslims together we get some comparative
perspective, but we also see how their relationships
with various people in French society--particularly
with each other--were really mediated through
their understandings of what it meant to be
French, who was French, who was not French.
For some Jews and Muslims there was a sense
of a religious proximity, because of the fact
that both faiths are Abrahamic, they share
certain rituals, they had certain common histories
in North Africa. For other Jews and Muslims,
being religious was--by definition almost--connected
to opposing loyalties in the context of the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict. But there are
many contexts in which that only did not produce
tremendous mutual hostility.
Consciousness of multi-ethnicity does not by definition
mean conflict, does not by definition mean
that Jews and Muslims will be unable to coexist.
What's taken place most recently in France
is not the only case of encounters between
Muslims and Jews in France that are happening
at this very moment. It's the one that's in
the headlines, it's the one that's violent,
and it troubles us, and it should trouble us.
But it's important to have a longer context
partly simply to realize that a sense of crisis,
a sense of deep questions about whether the
Republic can adapt, is not altogether new.
(applause)